the the left and the right in this
country have uh have flipped it's
what are they calling it's the
realignment i guess yeah the flipping or
the realignment
so like uh uh you know 10 years ago for
instance julian assange
biggest hero to the left right now they
hate his guts
uh a lot of leftists do however want him
pardoned as well so
it's more like the neolib establishment
left
who we're never really the biggest fans
of him for the most part anyway but
nobody likes them yeah but they're
they're the establishment i think what
what really
happened is that when trump got elected
the establishment cronies from the
republican party went to the democrats
their next closest alignment
but we are seeing an interesting
alignment where like um
i guess you voted uh is it publicly you
voted for yeah you voted for joe biden
yeah see like for us we're i think 10
years older than you
that would never happen that's like
because uh bush is essentially a neocon
he's a he's a warmonger he's you know an
interventionist he as part of like the
obama administration prosecuted more
journalists and whistleblowers
uh on you know than any other under the
espionage act more than
all the other presidencies before him
combined yeah so so
the left has become like even uh like
the left has become the authoritarians
it used to be that the republicans like
when i was growing up were the moral
authoritarians and the authoritarians
george w bush started these wars
and they wanted to ban like i've got art
downstairs where it's from the card game
magic the gathering
and in the 90s the right got some card
art band had to be changed
today the the band cards i have now came
from the left getting art banned
so it's like you know it's flipped the
the left is now
uh very much so in support of these uh
intelligence agencies for the most part
they're supporting joe biden he's
stacking his cabinet with lobbyists and
corporatists and goldman sachs
all of the worst corrupt people
imaginable
and it's like that that's exactly why i
voted for donald trump
there's a reason why i went down to
occupy wall street and i was like
you know the system's broken and there's
a reason why i'm like
joe biden's a bad guy because joe biden
was vice president during occupy wall
street
when all these leftists were coming out
and complaining interestingly enough too
you know in 2016 we had the rnc in the
dnc right
do you know uh the left didn't protest
the republicans
do you know they protested yeah the
democrats really the left showed up in
the thousands
tried storming the barricades to break
into the dnc nobody went to the
republican convention
trump was down there i was in where was
that was that was that
florida no no 2016. that was um
cleveland it wasn't atlanta was it no
i don't remember charlotte yes there was
one in charlotte yeah
well trump was there and he's like you
know uh giving a speech to the
republicans where he says
the you know these people uh and you
know he i think he's talking about the
pulse nightclub shooting he said
there's a lot of people who have
religious differences with this group
but these are americans these are our
people and they were attacked and
everyone starts clapping and cheering
meanwhile the democratic national
convention bernie sanders gets ripped
off and the left
is like trying to knock the barricades
down and jump over and storm into the
building
so the left was protesting now the
weirdest thing happens is you get like
these
faux progressive corporate you know
independent commentators
on youtube and such who are just like
the machine is right
i you know my favorite thing is is how
like rage against the machine the band
is very much rage for the machine now or
rage on behalf of the machine
they used to say things like what's the
famous line for you don't tell me
i won't do what you tell me now they're
saying fu you better do what we tell you
yeah how so so uh like lockdowns for
instance
the left is very much in favor of the
lockdowns and a stimulus like that's the
antithesis
of where the left would have been a
while ago definitely in favor of more
socialist policies and stuff
but not letting the government just
decree
that we're going to bar you from leaving
your homes which they're doing and
they're cheering for
i think my favorite thing about like joe
biden is when he said trunana shabbat of
pressure and the audience was cheering
for him
it's like now that's something
remarkable shout out to cassandra
fairbanks for pointing that out
yeah yeah yeah it's like everyone's
cheering what are they cheering for
so weird or bad of cath care i think you
know what happened is
i think uh you weren't old enough and i
mean there's no disrespect you're 24.
that's fine you're 24 right yeah
you like so like luke and i went through
occupy wall street
luke actually questioned democrats on
barack obama drone bombing kids and
things like that
and either got lied to or had people say
like yeah well he should have a better
father
who was that was that gibbs yep that's
barack obama's spokesperson
and his right-hand man throughout his
entire political career robert gibbs who
came out and literally got angry
he was like he should have had a better
father yeah yeah obama dropped a bomb
on on a kid in a civilian restaurant 16
year old american citizen
oh that's horrible yeah i mean obama and
obama was the veep i'm sorry biden was
the vp
he was overseeing iraq and his brother
got a lucrative multi-million dollar
contract for construction deals
it's like the the amount of evidence
that's come out against the bidens and
it's just like completely ignored by the
left because
either they're just tribalists who don't
care and so they're like
i just want to win and it's funny
because they're the ones saying the con
just want to own the libs i'm like dude
you just want to own the cons it's all
you want to do
it's so funny hearing you say this
because with my experience i've i feel
like i've seen these same exact thing
happen on the right
oh the wright just wants like like they
want to own the libs
and there are people who go on twitter
and just do you think that the right is
like heavily ideologically driven like
i've seen
i've found that the right tends to
already have kind of a set of like
presuppositions and then they go out of
their way to find uh support
for their already held beliefs rather
than the other way around which is
trying to approach it neutrally and then
forming your opinion based that's both
the left and the right
do you think it's both it's absolutely
terrible yeah so like oh yeah
and i would agree that it's both for
sure that's why i mean that's why i like
to
but right now right so so right now the
right has
more of the critical thinkers and it's
cancel culture that's basically why so
you'll see like i was down at occupy
wall street it wasn't really
i didn't agree with a lot of them
because they were very just like they're
extremely racist people like
some it was one of the most racist
things i've ever experienced at occupy
and uh but there were a lot of economic
populists there who weren't necessarily
in line with the weird racism stuff and
there were fights over it
the the i think the left has become like
predominantly racist relative to where
the right is
how so so occupy wall street they
segregated voting blocks based on race
well that i just can't even speak on
that since but would you agree that's
racist
to be like we're going to allow you to
vote for how things are run here
but we want all the brown people here
all the black people here all the
mexicans here and all the asians here
and you're all separated based on your
color and you can vote
only one vote per group no matter how
many of you there are wow
so if you have like you that's fair no
no i said that's weird
oh right right right so that's that that
so that's what's like what's happening
at these universities with like critical
race theory stuff
so they'd be like there's 10 white
people three asian people
and 15 black people you all get one vote
based on your race so you get three
votes
but that makes no sense because there's
different numbers of people that's what
occupy was doing
it's extremely racist and so that's when
i started being like well this is crazy
stuff man
anyway the left has become particularly
authoritarian
in in their application of things well
how have they become authoritarian
uh besides are you and are you yeah the
lockdowns
uh so so you also have cancelled culture
right but censorship supporting massive
private corporate
corporations corporations are are
essentially authoritarian
structures i'm i'm gonna have to ask you
more about this i'm such a leftist and
you're such a conservative no it's okay
it's just
how are the leftists supporting um
corporations
uh censorship i mean trump gave
tax cuts to corporations right he gave
taxes to everybody it but
substantially more so to the
corporations but what is what what's
wrong with that
uh well that's actually fairly
libertarian well no the problem with
that was that
he was going in there hoping that by
lowering corporate taxes we would see
more businesses coming back to the u.s
but that's just not what happened
well the economy did do ridiculously
well in 2019 but that wasn't because of
trump why not what was it because of it
was
because it's an economical fact that
after a recession the economy always
comes back stronger
after a recession 10 years ago yeah go
ahead look up the
go i'm not saying you're wrong i'm
saying if you can't give it credit to
trump then you can't blame uh george
bush for for the recession you can't
blame obama for the recovery
what did trump do to help with the
economy what did trump do is more
specifically even to help with
unemployment tariffs
uh there were there were immigration
raids on
processing plants which resulted like
it's it's a right effectors but tariffs
didn't do
that that cost american taxpayers
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in subsidies per job bringing back to
the us
right that's that's true that's the
point that's how the economy works so
if if you want to save money for the
businesses and the elites
then you allow them to send
their jobs to china for instance where
they pay people garbage and there's
human rights abuses
lowering so so let's take a look at what
joe biden his plan is there's two big
things he wants to increase the minimum
wage to 15
an hour and he wants to raise corporate
taxes by about 10 percent
if you go to a corporation a
manufacturer say someone who makes socks
and say we're going to raise your taxes
by 10 you've got to pay all of your
employees 30
more they're going to be like dude
you're squeezing me dry
i can't afford how am i supposed to do
this don't worry don't worry
we're going to have a free trade
agreement and you're going to be able to
run your factory in china
that's what that's what that's what
obama was doing and that's and it worked
so when was the last time minimum wage
went up
very very long time ago so so should it
be increased
no even though it hasn't been adjusted
for inflation or anything
yes so there's there's a bunch of
problems outside of what the
outside of the minimum wage and the
minimum wage is not a solution to the
problem
if uh so uh you need to sit down and
talk with like a small business account
that's exactly what i did to better
understand the issue i talked to an
accountant who represented like 300
small businesses
and i said we have a problem because
people don't have money to spend
right if they can't spend money
businesses can't take in money then they
can't pay taxes and they can't hire
people so we want the machine to flow
and he and yes completely correct
however
uh a hard increase of 30 or so because
this is what we saw in new jersey he
said here's what happens
he's like i just lost 30 of my clients
they shut down their businesses why
these people who run these small
businesses they're corporations too and
they have like 10 employees
but the owners aren't rich by any
stretch of the imagination
they might be paying their employees 10
bucks an hour because all they can pay
and then the guy who runs the bus is
only getting 50 000 a year
he's making a modest salary for him and
his family well then also they come in
and say
increase your your your wages your your
your your costs by 30
plus employment taxes right and all of a
sudden this guy's only been making 20
thousand a year and he says i can't
afford that i'd rather just go work as a
manager you know
a corporate for walmart or something so
that that has the impact specifically in
new jersey when they passed this laws
when i talked i went to an account to
ask him
you know tell me what's going on he said
he lost a ton of business accounts were
cancelled and businesses just shut
overnight
you can't force the economy to just
increase
there's one good thing about the minimum
wage and it's about exports
if everybody in the u.s is getting 15 an
hour
that means everybody can afford
something made in china better
and that's been one of the biggest
strategies of joe biden if we increase
the minimum wage increase corporate
taxes
we'll have all of our factories go to
china because joe biden and obama were
very much in favor of
you know these free trade agreements
notably the tpp and now the new
agreement that they've recently
negotiated without us joe biden is going
to get us in that day one
we're going to lose our jobs here but
the good thing is
it will it will make it so that somebody
who works at mcdonald's who makes 15
bucks an hour
can more easily afford afford the iphone
made by the slaves in china
see i think that's horrifying and
ultimately it's a downward trajectory
where we lose all of our jobs and then
eventually america just
sustains itself off of printing petro
dollars and that can only work so long
as we're blowing other people up and
threatening them that if they
you know disagree with our say building
an oil pipeline or natural gas pipeline
through syria
then we arm the rebels in syria to
destroy the government and wipe out
whole cities
which is basically what happened right
right but i mean i don't think that
like all the corporations would go to
china
no the the manufacturing ones the ones
that could maybe so trump you know
just out of curiosity for the joe biden
uh 15 minimum wage do you know if that's
just across the board or does that only
nationwide certain corporations uh i
don't know for sure and to be honest i
don't think he would do it
you know you know like i think he would
fail and he would try what you should do
instead is give
employees like a percentage of corporate
profit that way they only get extra
money if the corporate that's bernie
sanders policy yeah
like that's that's but i'm not
that way it wouldn't extort the business
wouldn't run them out of business
because they're already making the money
that i completely disagree you know
that's like uh isn't that market
socialism
is that what it that's bernie's bringing
it over bernie's platform that's like
worker co-op
nope right where everybody works
completely completely bad idea but keep
it you have to do it
i am not educated taylor form i'm not
educated in that i'm not about to
support or deny you know do you know why
the farms failed in these
socialist revolutions in these communist
revolutions depends on the revolution
well like basically everytime it's
because they made a bunch of scientists
go do the farming
a bunch of artists and they didn't know
how to farm exactly
and they killed birds and they killed
birds that was funny yes and they told
everyone to like melt down their their
tools or whatever like this is a bunch
of weird weird stuff
uh when you take a bunch of people who
don't know how to do something and then
give them control over a system
and they can't do it it failed thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time